I guys,
Tim Ferriss here want to to talk about cheat days.
So after writing the four hour body,
get a lot of questions about cheat days.
Do I still do them?
What are the components of a successful cheat day?
Why do a cheat day and how do people make mistakes?
What are the most common mistakes people make with Cheetos?
Let me lay it all out.
So do I still do cheat days?
Yes I do.
I love two days.
A lot of bear claws would love ice cream.
I love chocolate croissants.
The list goes on.
These are all things that I really enjoy.
And the purpose of cheat day is multifold.
Number one,
let's just say 90 out of 100 people at least will cheat on a diet.
So if you know you're going to cheat,
you can limit the damage by scheduling it in advance.
And this is the purpose of a cheat day.
And when you have a cheat day,
this digs into one of the mistakes that people make that is one week cycle.
It is not 24 hours.
So at some people like to do is they'll start at say eight or 9:00 PM one day
and go until nine,
10:00 PM the next day.
Uh,
that is going to increase the amount of fat you store and the damage that you
do.
So you want to limit the consumption period.
In other words,
from when you wake up to when you go to sleep,
it's one sleep cycle.
All right?
So there's the psychological benefit and the adherence improvement.
What does this mean?
If you're looking at a diet or you're looking at any type of behavioral change,
you're looking at,
say a method for quitting smoking.
It doesn't matter.
Any type of behavioral change.
There are really three,
I would say,
legs to the stool.
And in order of importance,
in my mind,
they are adherence.
Are you actually going to follow the program?
It doesn't matter how good the program is,
if you don't follow it.
So the good program that you follow is better than the perfect program that you
don't.
This is where,
for instance,
strict Paleo and strict veganism often fail.
And,
uh,
I get a lot of flack from experts on the Internet experts very often,
who will say,
well,
you should just have people go strict Paleo.
I can't believe you have beans.
People's intestines are going to explode.
You can't have them eat legumes.
And then the vegans go crazy in their own way and they say everybody should be
Vegan.
And the issue there is a strict people on either side that I'm doing you a favor
because it is a Trojan horse.
The slow carb diet as described in the four hour body gets more people to say
strict Paleo than probably any direct approach.
Why?
Because when I surveyed more than and tracked more than 2000 people,
I think it was more than 2,500 who followed the slow carb diet.
More than 50% said that it was the first diet they're able to stick with
consistently.
This is the key.
So it doesn't matter if you're strict Paleo for a week and then go back to
eating hohos and,
and drinking double gulps.
All right.
And uh,
same for any diet,
but if you are,
say even 80% or 90%,
uh,
to the letter with slow carb,
you will see tremendous benefits and fat loss.
And this is where if you look how to lose,
if you look up on search,
uh,
Z,
Google how to lose a hundred pounds on this low carb diet,
you will see a number of case studies and I've met dozens of people who've lost
a hundred,
200 pounds.
All right?
And that is why even though I experiment a lot with ketosis or it's people ask
me,
do you follow us low carb or Ketogenic Diet?
I generally recommend a slow carb.
I generally follow slow card because if you get it primarily right,
you still see benefits with ketosis.
If you are slightly off,
you eat too many elements,
you eat slightly too much of carbohydrate load and you knock yourself out of
ketosis.
All of a sudden you're just eating an a say 70% fat diet with a high glucose
level and you're screwed.
Okay,
so it's a very binary,
uh,
now,
so we have adherence.
Are you going to follow the program?
Number one,
I want to have the highest compliance rate,
the highest conversion rate in terms of behavioral change for say every hundred
people.
I look at the percentage of people who are going to follow it.
Number one,
adherence.
Number two,
is it effective?
Does it produce the,
the goals that you want or the,
the results that you want?
And then efficient is that making use of resources and your time in an efficient
manner.
All right.
Cheek Day limits the damage of cheating,
which is inevitable for most people.
And I'm not talking about somebody who's won the crossfit games five times.
Those are mutants.
Sure they can,
they can eat,
say sweet potatoes and chicken breasts and lentils all day,
every day forever because their freak shows.
Uh,
but the majority of people,
not true.
All right?
Biochemically,
uh,
it is also very helpful,
at least based on the data I have seen to spike your caloric load.
So you have one big Bolus of carbohydrate and calorie overload for a short
period of time too.
For instance,
prevent your thyroid production from downregulating.
Uh,
which if just by virtue of selecting different food on this low carb diet,
if you are,
say a sub maintenance calories,
is very,
very helpful for ensuring that you don't decrease your rate of cellular
metabolism and also natively affect hormone balance like testosterone
production.
Okay.
Uh,
this is also why,
for instance,
if you're a ketogenic diet nerd and you're trying to gain muscle mass,
it's very helpful to have a carbohydrate loading day.
And this could be the anabolic diet from a Moro Depasquale,
uh,
or a Dan Duchaine had a similar diet.
There are a number of different variations wherein you are provoking insulin
response once a week because it is an anabolic hormone.
Now,
overdosing on insulin obviously has its own issues,
but there are ways that you can say be to genic for five days,
Monday to Friday,
do a glycogen depletion workout on Saturday,
and then start force feeding yourself with carbohydrates that will be
preferentially stored as glycogen.
This would mean a very simple sugars.
I mean,
glucose.
And so,
and you're not going to want to go for say,
fructose,
uh,
and things that slow down that uptake.
But you can read more about that some other time,
but cheat days also,
biochemically,
the point I'm making are beneficial.
Uh,
and the third point,
okay,
putting aside the,
containing the damage,
putting aside the biochemical reason,
if we're just looking at adherence,
how do I get someone to follow us low carb diet for six months?
I do it by giving them a cheat day so they don't follow a strict,
strict,
strict diet for two weeks,
quit and then have a cheat month.
This is why people who've never lost weight before lose a hundred,
200 pounds or Ken.
And it's not uncommon at all.
All right.
What are some common mistakes?
So the first one I already touched on.
One way you can screw up a cheat day and make it harder to recover from because
very typically,
let's just say if you're choosing Saturday's your cheat day,
which a lot of people call Saturday,
then uh,
you will retain a lot of water for the next few days and generally be back to
your Friday.
Wait on say Tuesday.
And then you will see the scale and the scale is a blunt instrument.
I encourage you to use say,
a Dexa scan or at least a seven point skin caliper for tracking fat loss and
body composition.
Not just a scale,
it's a very blunt instrument.
But if we're looking at the total your weight cheat on,
on Saturday,
you retain a bunch of water,
okay?
You get to about Tuesday,
get back to your Friday,
wait,
and then for a few days you continue to see a decrease,
which is decreasing body fat.
Uh,
sometimes that is mass because you're gaining muscle at the same time.
This is very prevalent with women who get frustrated is they're not tracking
body fat or body composition,
the tracking the scale.
So this is a Meta problem that is particularly an issue with women who have been
unfortunately brainwashed and,
uh,
led to really focus on the scale.
But you're going to be gaining muscle because generally you'll be consuming more
protein than,
uh,
with prior diets.
Okay?
So number one is,
uh,
we talked about limiting it to a wake cycle,
right?
Number one.
Number two,
are you doing anything to Blunt Your Insulin or glucose response?
And Trust me,
it's going to spike anyway.
But are you doing anything to mitigate the damage?
So the damage control chapter in the four hour body,
very important.
One of the things that I will very frequently do is I will have a small healthy
breakfast.
It could be primarily vegetables.
It will almost always have a decent fiber.
So it could be a small amount of spinach saying with a little bit of you could
just eat some lentil straight out of the can or doll.
Uh,
and Chile,
it doesn't really matter,
but something that is going to blunt your cortisol and that Cortisol,
glucose and insulin response,
uh,
then throughout the day,
okay.
On top of that,
let's just say you have Kathy and plus a little bit of grapefruit juice.
All right?
So I'm not going to get it into a neural engine in and how that interacts as a
component or a compound within a group for juice and how it interacts with
coffee.
But suffice to say,
you will be expelling let's say more calories.
If you combine those two and you also can use fructose is the sugar in the fruit
in small doses to help blunt your,
again Lucas and insulin spikes,
right this,
this will decrease the amount of fat that you store.
And my prep,
my preferred method here is freshly squeezed grapefruit juice cause it's
delicious.
A little bit of that say half cup or a cup is cheat day.
So go crazy if you want and then have coffee very shortly thereafter.
And then that's what I'm going to go nuts.
All right,
so we have small meal,
which is going to be fiber,
a fiber heavy,
then you're going to have caffeine.
It's an,
it's an optional but say caffeine plus a little bit of fructose.
Uh,
if you're following the four hour body prescription and you will would also take
pag during this period.
So that is uh,
for the,
for the meals before bed,
you're looking at Alpha lipoic acid,
garlic,
which I believe is Alison extract.
And then green tea extract.
A,
you're not going to want to take that before bed,
but you're gonna take those prior to meals to minimize the damage.
Other things that can be helpful.
So we talked about the basics are Berberine,
and I'll let you guys look that up.
Berberine.
Very,
very interesting.
Uh,
and if you have,
uh,
if you are talking to your medical doctor,
and this is only for use in consult with a medical doctor,
a,
you can sometimes get something called Akar boasts a,
which can also minimize your glucose response to foods of this time.
All right.
The,
the,
I would say most common mistake that people make aside from going splitting it
over two days is restraint.
Okay?
What does this mean?
This means you say,
okay,
I'm going to cheat.
I'm only going to have a cheat.
I'm going to have one sheet sandwich or I'm going to cheat,
but I'm going to cheat with Rice.
Uh,
and the cheating clean can be done.
And again,
there are mutants for whom this is enough of a release valve that that can keep
them on the stricter diet during the week.
For most folks,
if you don't have a real cheat day,
meaning eat whatever the hell you want,
drink whatever the hell you want.
Uh,
if you don't do that,
you're going to cheat later in the week.
Why?
Because you didn't scratch that itch.
And in fact,
and I'm not saying we're not aiming for bulemia or anything like that here,
but I will deliberately try to eat to the point where it makes me a little
uncomfortable,
a little sick,
okay?
And I've gotten a lot of flack for this too,
but trust me,
it works.
After tracking and watching thousands and thousands of people do this,
if you half ass cheat date,
you're going to cheat again.
And that defeats the whole purpose.
All right?
So really go for the gold.
And uh,
what you'll find is very often at the end of cheat day,
you will be dying to get back to your regular slow carb diet.
You're clean diet and over time,
very often,
naturally you will start to cut back on cheat day.
Uh,
but in the beginning phases,
particularly when you're establishing this habit,
this routine,
you want to go for the Golden Cheat Day,
right?
You don't have,
you shouldn't actually vomit.
You're not going for that.
Okay?
So there's a,
there's a goldilocks point,
but it's like,
okay,
if I'm still hungry,
I'm still Jonesing for junk food.
Amen.
Have another kit Kat.
You know,
have another croissant,
have another,
whatever the hell it is that you're Jonesing for.
Have some more ice cream.
And I really don't have assets.
So if you see me on cheat day,
every girl I've ever dated has been disgusted by the display of gluttony.
Uh,
there's has,
don't cheat day and I love it.
So there we go.
Uh,
the next mistake that people make is thinking to themselves,
well,
if one sleep cycle is,
or a one sleep cycle,
and then one week cycle is where I'm going to focus my cheat day on,
why don't I just do that twice a week?
So instead of doing say 8:00 AM to 8:00 PM,
I'm going to do 8:00 AM to noon one day,
and then I'm going to do maybe half a day,
some other day during the week.
This will almost always,
from what I've observed,
lead to more fat gain,
less progress than otherwise.
All right?
So if it's cheat day,
cheat day,
then you want to focus it within one week cycle.
I recommend a Saturday for social reasons because very often if you make it,
say a Wednesday could be a Friday for some people,
then they'll go out,
they'll have a bunch of booze on the weekend and they'll end up eating pizza or
some other crap.
Anyway,
all right,
don't get to cheat days.
One Cheat Day.
That is it.
Now,
if your goal is not primarily fat loss and is masking,
instead there are approaches and this is more advanced.
So you want to get a couple of months look arm under your belt first where you
could follow,
say a ketogenic diet or a slow carb diet and then spike,
uh,
say for one meal on a Wednesday with something like brown rice.
And then again on Saturday.
Okay.
But in less,
you have saint less than 10% body fat.
Not Allowed to do that.
Generally Charles polycom would say,
if you don't have penis skin on your abs and not allowed eat carbs after your
workout and you're certainly not allowed to have two chief.
So it's crass as that is pretty good guideline.
All right,
so that's one.
And uh,
those are,
I would say the most common mistakes that I've observed in cheat days.
And there are those people out there would say no cheat days.
Crazy.
You should have a cheat meal.
Well,
is a cheat meal going to scratch the Itch for you in your heart of hearts well
enough so that you are not going to cheat at all later in the week?
Yes or no?
The answer from most people is no.
All right.
And whenever I get some diet guru or self proclaimed
leader of some cult who comes out to attack me because it's low carb,
legumes,
oh my God,
lentils,
they're going to make your head explode.
You're going to give yourself auto immune disorder.
Look,
there's some people,
yes,
if you've already had a diagnosed issue with these things,
you probably shouldn't need them for the vast majority,
you're fucking fine.
Okay.
And uh,
whenever someone gives you a very strong opinion,
you should ask them where are your data,
what evidence do you have?
And at this point for our body came out seven years ago,
seven years of watching hundreds of thousands of readers go through this.
And I would encourage everybody to check out the basics of this low carb diet.
If you haven't checked it out before,
I'm not going to get into it right now.
You can find it for free.
Just look up how to lose a hundred pounds on this low carb diet.
And it'll pop right up with all the basic guidelines.
And then if you really want to get into the nitty gritty two chapters in the
four hour body that I would recommend everybody check out or a slow carb diet
chapter two,
which really gets into some of the nitty gritty details and little things you
can tweak that make a big difference.
And then damage control,
which is basically an expanded version of how to minimize the fact gain.
Even if in some cases I kid you not,
you could consume and I have consumed say 10,000 plus calories in a day and then
clocked in with lower body fat a few days later then prior to the cheat day.
So how does that work while I already give you some of the tools,
but for the 15 or 20 pages that really,
really get into this,
I think it's around that could be shorter.
Uh,
you can go to the four hour body and check it out.
So that's where our body.com all spelled out or just go to Amazon or whatever
other fine book retail and you can check it out.
Hopefully that helps.
But Cheat Day,
I still stand by it.
Sorry,
slow carb still stand by it completely.
And uh,
hopefully those tips and recommendations help you to a joy more.
Succeed more on whichever day you choose,
suffer less and gain less fat and lose more fat.
So enjoy guys.
Thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this video,
I want to propose you check out the podcast,
the Tim Ferriss Shell.
Why has it been number one on iTunes across all categories?
In some cases,
number one in business,
why does it have 70 million plus downloads?
Because I interviewed world class performers from athletics business.
That includes billionaires from everything imaginable,
entertainment to tease out the routines,
the habits,
the tools that you can use.
So check it out.
The Tim Ferriss show.